michel s'est logé à montréal vincent
marissal à montréal et daniel lessard à
tahoua bonsoir messieurs 1er tour de
table sur la le premier cabinet de
justin trudeau c'est un premier geste
important qui sera posée mercredi matin
je commence avec vous un michel si roger
vos attentes
plon fraport souvient des prédictions à
l'isi mais vous attendent pour mercredi
michel d'abord on risque d'avoir un
cabinet plus petits la parité hommes
femmes ce qui est un message en soit il
faut juste une affaire mathématiques
faire ça mais ensuite il faudra voir que
qu'elle et quels sont les autres
équilibrer les autres questions qui
doivent être réglés par exemple combien
d'anciens députés libéraux on met dans
le cabinet combien de nouveaux on veut
apporter le plus de renouveau possible
c'est normal en même temps un député qui
était intelligent excès qui sera pas
ministre
c'est quelqu'un qui devient dans notre
système très rapidement quelqu'un qu'il
faut occuper parce que sinon il va
s'occuper lui-même cg20 de beaune b on
dit par exemple que pablo rodriguez ce
député qui a regagné son siège à la
chambre des communes ne sera pas miner
selon nos informations sa déception il y
en aura des déceptions vincent forcément
avec un petit cabinet s'il est vrai que
ce cabinet tourne autour de deux
douzaines c'est ce qu'on disait à la fin
de la campagne chez les libéraux on ne
savait pas encore à quel point il serait
majoritaire mais je pense que justin
trudeau vraiment si tony éviter le
l'imega cabinet comme celui de paul
martin qui étaient 38 ou 39 leur faisait
des réunions qui ne finissait plus puis
finalement il n'y avait pas de décision
qui se prenait bernard landry en 2003
aussi on disait souvent que le convoi de
limousines ne faisait quasiment toute la
grande allée à québec avec quelque chose
comme 38 ministres aussi ça aucun sens
alors s'ils s'y tient et puis qu'est la
parité homme femme puis des directions
régionales au canada aussi évidemment je
pense que des députés comme pago
rodriguez qui est malheureusement été
élu à montréal risquent de souffrir par
contre ce que mélanie joly serait
ministre junior c'était dans les cartons
tout cas vers la fin de la campagne
mais justin trudeau c'est compliqué elle
n'est pas en même temps et beaucoup
d'arbitrage à faire et à la fin il ya
pour un montant de 162 séduit
qui seront pas qu'ils seront pas au
ministre de toute évidence mais il s'est
mis tellement de balises la parité
évidemment il ya la balise les balises
régional au canada ont ils échappent
jamais et puis la balise de l'expérience
aussi
c'est compliqué et ça les ports et en
même temps il peut facilement faire des
choix peut expliquer aux déçus on
m'écoute et on pourrait probablement une
prochaine fois dominé d'été lui il veut
se démarquer aussi d'inde hier comme par
exemple on parlait de stéphane dion tout
à leur plus haut dans l'émission
beaucoup de gens paris il ya des
informations qui vont dans ce sens là
qu'il ne sera pas nommé à
l'environnement parce que justement
justin trudeau veut se démarquer
ouais si vous me permettez une
comparaison peut-être boiteuse un peu
patrice mais à 1980 quand son père a
formé son dernier cabinet à il avait
aucun des buts et si je me souviens bien
élu à l'ouest de winnipeg il avait fait
appel à deux vieux sénateur ben nelson
et zones hors ue pour combler ces postes
là justin trudeau en poste problème là
il a le luxe d'avoir à de bons candidats
de bons députés élus dans toutes les
régions du pays
il ya des gens qui disaient ces jours-ci
et puis bon c'est elle exagère un peu
mieux du matériel pour faire deux bons
cabinet et à propos de ils vont faire un
seul 24 26 28 on verra mercredi
sauf que il ya il ya une attitude très
grande mais il ya aussi une attitude
très grande comme le disait récents pour
faire de la peine à bien des gens et ça
et s'il n'y a pas beaucoup de prix de
consolation à donner ces gens là des
présidences de comité c'est bon ça vous
occupe pendant plusieurs semaines mais
c'est pas c'est pas un gros gros gros
cadeau de noël
et il a les coudées franches et on
s'entend là-dessus mais la prima il peut
faire ce qu'il veut
il doit rien à personne absolument et il
ya eu certains députés qui auraient été
élu sans juste être donnée à une très
très grosse marty qui ont été élus parce
que c'était justin trudeau parce qu'il a
fait une excellente campagne
le programme en tu me dis juste être une
home hardware exactement pas soin aux
conservateurs une seconde je vous
entends denis lebel qui va être gros
chef du parti conservateur pour exprimer
la voix québécoise on rappelle que plus
de députés conservateurs qui en avait
avant l'élection et une progression
québec
ça ressemble à quoi ce qui se passe aux
vingt sept chez les conservateurs
actuellement la sas bousquet ça se
bouscule au portillon en tout cas pour
à prendre la direction intérimaire et
loyers loi 110 du parti pendant ce temps
là vont la vraie course se prépare le
notamment certain jason kenny qui de
toute évidence a déjà une certaine
longueur d'avancé alors faudra quand
même nommer quelqu'un à ses bientôt pour
assurer la cohésion et puis ensuite le
travail aux communes cette idée de
cochefs lot de direction bicéphale elle
a été lancé en fin de semaine par denis
lebel oui députés du québec et sa
collègue michèle grimpeurs qui est de
calgary - lé parle pas français lui
évidemment pas le français alors on
rejoint aussi lorsqu'on appelle souvent
les deux solitudes
c'est une idée ma foi à créative mais
peut-être un peu difficile à faire
fonctionner la dent d'un quotidien de la
chambre des communes
on se rappelle par exemple québec
solidaire qui n'était pas du tout dans
la même situation mais qui avait
toujours ses deux chefs c'est d'une
porte parole aussi ça devient peu de
scènes normalement dans notre système
politique
ça prend un chef parce que c'est déjà
assez compliqué surtout de de gérer le
contrôle et un caucus normalement et
puis ensuite à la période des questions
comment on fait un coup denis lebel mais
ça montre pas aussi que personne qui
incarne les deux aspects elle est là la
france québécoise et il le reste du
canada ça montre que personne peut
incarner rapidement comme le faisait
monsieur moroni comme le fait quand
monsieur un peu quand même en union en
faisant l'union des deux parties daniel
y aurait 200 kénémé prendre pour raisons
que vous connaissez il peut pas se
retrouver dans ce poste-là
ah et pour ce qui est du duo lebel ron
paul mauges journal beaucoup de
problèmes avec ce sont deux voleurs
parce que ça finit par ressembler à
l'anglophone qui faisait déjà partie
francophone qu'elle porte parole de
service c'est toujours très dangereux
cette approche a d'autres considérations
et si tout à fait anecdotique tout à
fait trivial si vous voulez qui va
habiter à stornoway le vrai chef ou une
demi chef millions le trajet kolaka 5-1
prime de 80 mille dollars qui vient avec
le poids si la divise en deux
chez ces objets je veux vous entendre
sur une histoire là je veux pas vous
daniel vous insultez maison qu'à ottawa
- quoique c'est vrai qu'il ya plus des
bouchons il y en a plus le matin des
bouchons sur la 417 en trop mais il ya
eu une étude pour faire face aux
bouchons dans les grandes villes
canadiennes et l'étude conclue par des
économies ça prend des péages comme à
londres chelsea au gvt est peut-être
entendu une minute tout à l'heure sur le
plateau il veut rien de savoir de ça
court terme des péages
on n'est pas très surpris que monsieur
position vous devez savoir deux seuls à
court terme
écoutez le problème c'est qu'à un moment
donné il va falloir faire quelque chose
mais un policier dont l'horizon est bien
sûr de 4 ans va toujours dire moi je
veux faire élire dans quatre ans pour
moi qui vois mon nom sur ces péages là
alors on a un problème mais la réalité
c'est que l'argent qu'on perd en
conjectures commence est un problème
réel j'étais à québec en fin de semaine
essayer de traverser québec à l'heure de
pointe de patrice vous allez voir c'est
presque pire vraiment rien c'est presque
rendu comme ça alors il ya des problèmes
de cette loi partout et ils voient
comment valois commencé à regarder des
solutions et les solutions ce projet de
voie réservée pour les autobus là il
faut regarder quelque chose de plus
globale que ça et ça se fait bon à new
york pour payer pour rentrer à manhattan
mais c'est pas beaucoup la norme en
amérique là c'est plus en europe
michèle ouimet sa part d' on n'en sait
pas beaucoup la norme et puis l'idée du
pea je pense champlain ou ailleurs dans
la grande région de montréal a fortement
reculé le 19 octobre dernier avec
l'élection de monsieur trudeau lui comme
le npd d'ailleurs s'était engagé à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas de péage sur le
nouveau compte champlain ça semble être
une décision ferme
reviendra-t-il plus tard peut-être avec
un plan plus général plus large avec par
exemple son programme d'infrastructures
le qu'il veut ambitieux peut-être avec
des programmes de transport en commun
auquel on pourrait greffer quelques
péage mais pour le moment c'est certain
que justin trudeau que des députés ou à
montréal et des deux côtés du fleuve
d'ailleurs reviendra certainement pas
sur sa promesse de ne pas imposer de
péage rats l'idée en ce moment elle est
théoriquement débat table et puis je
pense que c'est sur ces chercheurs
aujourd'hui amène de l'eau au moulin
mais pour ce qui est du nouveau pont
champlain entre l'idée à fortin marc
daniel il n'y a pas remarqué des gros
projets déjà ottawa ya des gros projets
de trains à tahoua actuellement mais il
n'y a pas un politicien qui veut lever
la main en disant on va créer des péages
métropolitains le dernier c'est gerald
tremblay ici ouais etc tu sais pas c'est
pas mais même adore d'une campagne
électorale c'est pas une solution très
très très très attirante sauf que il ya
la congestion c'est un aspect
extrêmement important mais aussi le
vieillissement des infrastructures qui
vont falloir réparer ça va vous coûter
des fortunes
je suis allé beaucoup aux états unis
depuis deux ans basketball oblige
et on paye partout sur n'importe quel
petit bout de route ont fini par payer
quelques sous donc un bout de paix c'est
ce que c'est quoi la solution
incontournable est ce que de toute façon
ils n'auront pas le choix de le faire
dans deux cinq dix ans voilà la question
est lancée le basket-ball jette pas
mieux au basket ball d'amiens non c'est
moi au film sa peinture et vous très
bien monsieur beaucoup plus de talent
que moi c'est toujours un plaisir merci
a bientot mais encore